cette année apple va sortir sa seizième
version d'ios eyeos 16 alors il ya déjà
pas mal de choses qui commencent à se
dessiner on commence à voir à quoi
pourrait ressembler qu'elle pourrait
très bien et les nouveautés qui vont
arriver sera y aurait 16 alors y aura un
os 16 jours ipad aux essais c'est encore
autre chose sans voir parra peut être
une prochaine fois d'ailleurs si ça vous
intéresse qu on parle et bien des
rumeurs d'un ipad 2 16 ans de le marquer
dès maintenant en commentaire j'ai
identifié pas moins de douze rumeurs
potentiellement crédible sur ce qui
pourrait arriver sur votre iphone en
2022 et ça c'est plutôt bien allez on y
va
[Musique]
et là ouais en 2022 pourquoi parce que
normalement on devrait retrouver la
grande conférence des développeurs la
daba l'uda badiou d'ici serait présenté
au mois de juin 2022 si apple reste sur
le même calendrier que les années
précédentes dans laquelle sera présenté
bien évidemment et bien toutes ces
nouveautés software et notamment à un os
qu un peu je dirais l'annoncent phare de
cette d'abeilles ou d'abeille ou 10,6
alors avant d'avoir toutes ces annonces
officialisées au mois de juin 2022 ça
nous laisse encore un petit peu de temps
pour essayer de voir entre apercevoir ce
qu'apple pourrait faire et là où va ce
qu'il pourrait aller si vous êtes un
utilisateur d'iphone vous êtes
probablement déjà habitués à un os et
ios 15 et toutes ses versions qui sont
arrivés derrière ils continueront
arriver avec toutes les mises à jour et
les nouvelles fonctionnalités qui arrive
à chaque fois et qui sont vraiment
intéressants alors il ya plein de choses
qui devraient arriver sur un os plein de
choses un jour où son papier ça me
paraît assez séduisant il ya des choses
que je crois être un petit peu moins
mais avant toute chose je vous invite à
venir vous abonnez vous abonner oui
pourquoi et bien pour tout savoir son
actu taille tout connaître que ce soit
des tests produits des rumeurs comme ça
des news on se fait plein de choses des
guides d'achat des tutos des astuces
vous invite à cliquer sur le bouton
rouge s'est pas déjà fait et si vous
êtes déjà abonné actionner la cloche
pour être notifié dès qu une prochaine
vidéo arrivera et croyez-moi des vidéos
il y en a pas qu'il y en aura encore
plein d'autres donc ça c'est une bonne
nouvelle donc on y va on clique on
actionne la cloche et ça c'est chouette
on commence tout de suite par la toute
première fuite c'est une suite qui nous
fait état d'un nouveau designer aussi
attendre qui peut effectivement est-ce
quelque chose qui soit un petit peu
retravaillé mais souvenez-vous et je
sais pas si vous l'avez vu ma vidéo je
vous parle des rumeurs l'iphone 14 on
nous annonce qu'apple ne mettrai plus
d'ancrage en tout cas pas comme ils le
font actuellement avec ses iphone même
si effectivement les iphone 13 on voit
que l'encoche a diminué sur les côtés
pour venir un peu plus petit néanmoins
il reste quand même cette grande encore
en haut des iphone est là a priori cette
encoches regardez c'est quand même un
petit peu devant elle pourrait
complètement disparaître on aurait un
tout petit trou et puis à côté petite
bulle dans laquelle retrouverez le
système de failles saïdi alors ça c'est
dans ma vidéo de rumeurs aller la voir
si vous n'avez pas déjà vu du coup il
faudrait une intégration logicielle pour
permettre ce nouvel affichage permettre
que la partie écran utilisable avec un
peu plus haut et bien c'est ce que
viendrait faire notamment ici à ios
scène avec cette nouveauté qui serait
vraiment chouette il en profitera
également pour venir à re design est un
petit peu les icônes présentes sur leur
iphone alors ça c'est un truc et déjà
annoncé depuis un petit moment on 2 on
nous annonce effectivement des icônes
proche de mac os big four à voir de quoi
ça me paraît assez logique de voir
l'écran qui ait autant aussi c'est
encore j'ai effectivement et supprimer
en tout cas c'est assez normal et très
crédible et puis bien évidemment donner
un petit coup de frais aux icônes ça me
paraît aussi assez normal donc sans
paraben évidemment plus tard alors
deuxième point un deuxième fuite qui est
assez intéressant deuxième rumeur qui
est assez intéressant une fois de plus
si vous avez regardé ma vidéo sur les
rumeurs de l'iphone 14 et bien je vous
ai annoncé que apple travaillerait sur
un système pour pouvoir envoyer un
message d'urgence lorsque vous n'auriez
pas de réseau ça marcherait comment ça
marcherait en passant par le satellite
donc votre téléphone se connecteraient
aux satellites et on verrait un sms aux
services d'urgence et à vos contacts
également il ya quelques contacts que
vous aurez sélectionné alors donnant vos
coordonnées gps bien évidemment ça il
faut aussi intégrer d'un point de vue
logiciel et croyez moi c'est à dire
quand même un petit peu de taff sa part
est réparé a effectivement de se dire ok
ok ok apple veut toujours aller plus
loin en termes de sécurité que ce soit
sur de la sécurité de la donne et privé
ou lors sur la sécurité des utilisateurs
donc à les sécuriser son utilisateur
tout en disant écoutez vous pouvez avoir
un problème lorsqu'on vit dans un
endroit où vous n'avez pas de réseau
comment vous pouvez faire eh bien nous
on vous assure que quel que soit
l'endroit sur la planète où vous allez
être et bien vous aurez toujours la
possibilité d'appeler les secours si
vous avez un problème donc ça c'est bien
bon après il leur faut le temps pour
arriver mais ça c'est une autre histoire
et la troisième rumeurs qui va dans ce
sens là j'en ai également parlé pendant
la vidéo sur l'iphone 14 eh bien c'est
la détection d'accident si vous avez un
accident et bien votre iphone vous
demandera si ça va et si vous ne
répondez pas qu'est ce qu'il fera il
appellera les services d'urgence il
appellera les secours et cela il faut
aussi l'intégrer d'un point de vue
logiciel ça fonctionnera avec votre
accéléromètre probablement de votre
gyroscope mais ça demande aussi un très
gros travail de la part d'apple pour
venir développer cette solution est une
fois de plus ça va dans le lied et la
sécurité que apple vous sécurisez votre
iphone vous avez effectivement un
compagnon intelligent mais en plus de ça
qui vient vraiment vous assistez et vous
aider dans les moments difficiles de la
vie est en tout cas ça me semble être
assez logique alors quatrième point qui
est intéressant j'y crois un petit peu
moins mais je trouve assez intéressant
apple travaillerait sur la sortie d'un
casque de réalité virtuelle réalité
augmentée pourquoi pas de la réalité
mixte alors on nous annonce que
potentiellement 2022 ça pourrait
commencer à arriver et que du coup apple
travaillerait sur de la réalité
augmentée plus plus plus plus sur son
iphone je veux bien croire à ça je sais
que tim cook croient davantage dans la
réalité augmentée plus que la réalité
virtuelle qui va plus enfermer les gens
mais force est de constater qu'avec tout
annonces qui ont été faites cette année
sur le lancement du metavers ça peut les
obliger de commencer à annoncer des
choses commençaient à se positionner
même si j'imagine que derrière il
travaille depuis un petit moment donc
l'arrivée potentielle d'un casque
d'apple là dessus pour pouvoir se
connecter au métal alors on rappelle en
quelques secondes à le métavers ckoi et
bien c'est une nouvelle interface pour
vous connecter à internet vous n'auriez
pas votre navigateur internet vous venez
naviguer sur votre ordinateur un peu
classiquement vous l'auriez au travers
d'un casque de réalité virtuelle ou de
réalité augmentée pour pouvoir vous
connecter de façon plus immersive au web
pour pouvoir venir naviguer avant du
divertissement et des infos que ça fait
un peu plus intéressant et plus immersif
on se parle quelque chose à l'horizon
cinq à dix ans on est vraiment
tranquille on a relativement le temps là
dessus mais apple commence à travailler
dessus alors je ne crois pas qu apple
annonce tout de suite un casque que ce
soit de réalité virtuelle ou de réalité
augmentée parce que le métavers d'époque
on va arriver on sait qu'apple prend en
règle générale son temps donc ça j'y
crois assez peu par contre qu'ils
viennent intégrer de nouvelles
fonctionnalités de réalité augmentée j'y
crois davantage et pourquoi pas pour des
usages la destination des professionnels
on verra bien évidemment tout ça au mois
de juin alors la cinquième rumeur elle
m'intéresse j'y crois davantage ce qu'on
appellera le widget interactif alors
regardez je vous le monde ça c'est une
photo qui circule sur le web qui vous
montrent ce que pourrait être ce widget
interactif alors ça serait une capture
d'écran d'un os 16 en cours de
développement donc on y va tranquille
tranquille on voit que c'est le licr qui
s'appelle knicks apple pro qui l'a
publié oui il a mis son nom partout ça
me paraît assez logique alors qu'est ce
qu'on voit ici on sait que les widgets
sont arrivés il ya quelques temps sur
ios ça serait un regroupement de widgets
par catégorie hockey est-ce que ça a un
sens pourquoi pas regardez on voit
effectivement ici alors ils nous ont mis
des infos chaque info chaque on pourrait
mettre le nom vous voulez par exemple
maison par exemple travaillent par
exemple divertissement multimédia est
bien là bon effectivement on a de la
météo on va avoir une info qui va le
lier à hammam pour pouvoir faire un
appel vidéo vous avez votre vous rendez
vous donc le trajet ici votre colle
votre photo et vos notifications vous
auriez votre télécommande ok bon on voit
ça c'est simple en dessous on aurait
également de la météo pouvoir passer de
la musique lancé un chrono déverrouiller
la torche
ok donc on voit effectivement que si
c'est un regroupement par catégorie moi
je le fais aujourd'hui sur mon iphone là
par exemple eh bien c'est tout un côté
un peu plus professionnel où je veux
avoir allait bien tout ce qui va être
youtube tout ce qui va être facebook
instagram
la gestion des différents réseaux
sociaux mais fichiers mais note quelques
applications pour venir faire de la
vidéo bref je retrouve tout ici alors je
le classe également ici sur un côté un
peu plus familial divertissement
informations avec de la musique avec du
divertissement et notamment du
divertissement vidéo avec de l'actualité
quelques journaux que je lis ici c'est
plus un perso avec mes courses avec la
gestion de ma maison avec les finances
et si c'est plus lié au transport avec
tout ce qui va être notamment
réservations au niveau de l'avion au
niveau du train au niveau du bus métro
des voitures enfin bref ce que le
classifie déjà aujourd'hui donc est ce
qu'il ya un intérêt à se dire ok on va
faire exactement la même chose mais on
va le faire ici au travers d'un
regroupement de widgets pourquoi pas
alors comme c'est milla je ne pense pas
je pense que si c'est effectivement et
bien un leak qui sort d'ailleurs s16
c'est une préversion était choisie est
celle des choses parce qu'il leur faut
un petit peu de temps on arrivera bien
évidemment vous savez cette présenté au
mois de juin 2022 avec les bêta qui
commencent à sortir pour une arrivée
grand public à l'automne donc on encore
un petit peu de temps ça pourrait être
intéressant de regrouper des widgets par
groupes d'ailleurs je sais pas ce que
vous en pensez diplôme en bas en
commentaire la 6ème fuite rumeurs et
bien c'est sûr l'application caméra qui
serait retravaillé alors regardé mon
application caméra elle est ici
aujourd'hui elle fonctionne comme ça
vous le connaissez un photo vidéo
cinématique ralentis accélérés on
pourrait venir travailler pour le rendre
encore plus sexy ça ne se trouve pas y
praille prat sexy aujourd'hui apple
pourrait aller beaucoup plus loin et
nous sexy fit un petit peu cette
application la rente j'en sais rien un
peu plus coloré un peu moins austère
qu'on comprenne plus facilement en fait
ce qui se passe alors si aujourd'hui si
vous êtes un utilisateur d'apple on
arrive à comprendre un peu mais si on
faisait des icônes sait pas toujours
toujours évident je pense qu'apple a
encore du travail cette application et
je crois assez à ces rumeurs qui disent
effectivement et bien que qu apple
viendrait améliorer et optimiser toute
l'expérience logiciel sur la partie
photo en tout cas ça me semble assez
logique la 8e rue moeurs et des quick
note des notes rapides vous l'avez
aujourd'hui sur votre mac vous venez sur
le côté et voyez en bas là vous avez la
petite note là qui a envie d'arriver
vous appuyez dessus et hop vous avez une
petite note qui s'ouvre vous pouvez
commencer à travailler donc ça on l'a
ici et c'est vachement bien mais il nous
manque cette petite crique note sur son
iphone alors j'aimerais bien peut-être
je sais pas en allant chercher un petit
slide sur le côté vous viendriez
naviguer florian petit slide j'en sais
rien en bas à droite pour avoir votre
clique nox ou ça vachement bien parce
que moi j'utilise beaucoup les notes
lorsque kg une idée aux petites notes
rapides art project dans mon application
note je dois appuyer dessus je doit
l'ouvrir ça prend un certain temps donc
ça paraîtrait vraiment bien et en termes
de productivité d'avoir accès à vos
notes très rapidement la huitième
rumeurs c'est une application qui
arriverait qui s'appellerait air things
les choses rr fing pourquoi ça fait de
regrouper deux choses principal est bien
la gestion de vos appareils connectés
apple notamment vaud et repose
aujourd'hui pour piloter vos épaules
vous faites quoi vous avez dans votre
bluetooth et vous pouvez venir commander
vos herbes folles c'est pas mal mais on
pourrait faire mieux pourrait en tout
cas imaginé une application dédiée tel
qu'on peut retrouver sur android oui ici
même sur un os avec par exemple
d'envoyer les applications au galaxy
buzz jbl surface audio ou encore un
marshall donc il ya un vrai sens et en
plus pour y est piloté quoi et bien vos
airtag parce que pour piloter vos
attaques menées dans l'application
localiser vous auriez donc une seule
application qui viendraient piloter vous
objets connectés à votre iphone et ça me
paraîtrait vraiment aller dans le bon
sens donc ça j'y crois beaucoup en tout
cas je le souhaite beaucoup la 9e
rumeurs la 9e info c'est un centre de
contrôle qui serait revu et corrigé le
centre de contrôle c'est vrai qu'il est
pas mal on peut venir de personnaliser
rave des icônes supprimer des icônes
mais là on viendrait rajouter sur le
dessus une partie multi tâches vous avez
toutes vos applications ouvertes pour
pouvoir naviguer rapidement dans aller
sur une âme si vous le souhaitiez on
voudra peut regrouper un combo et
pourquoi pas venir lancer un multitâche
très rapidement à partir du centre de
contrôle bon pourquoi pas ce que je veux
bien croire effectivement ici c'est que
le centre de contrôle ils demandent à
être vus ils demandent à évoluer
peut-être regroupant des applications
pétrole ayant des groupes d'applications
je ne sais pas c'est en allant plus loin
c'est pareil c'est assez fonctionnel
mais on peut faire mieux la deuxième
fuite c'est sur l'écran de verrouillage
l'écran de verrouillage tel que vous
l'avez actuellement ok il est pas mal
mais on peut aller un peu plus loin il
ya une rumeur qui fait état d'une
nouvelle fonctionnalité qui arriverait
alors attendez j'ai le nom exact elle
s'appellerait série reply suggestions ça
veut dire que lorsque vous recevriez un
sms et bien siri vous mettrez des
suggestions rapide pour répondre en un
clic regardez on l'a ici je vous aimais
une capture d'écran d'un tweet qui vous
montre à quoi ça pourrait ressembler
alors c'est une conception maison mais
c'est pour essayer de traduire un petit
peu le regard des dessous montre la
deuxième photo on le voit d'un peu plus
près seul quickreply en fait vous auriez
ça pour sevrier un petit message là tu
veux des jeunes à midi et vous pourriez
dire ouais bien sûr à quelle heure ou
alors non je peux pas aujourd'hui vous
auriez donc des messages rapides un clic
vous répondriez ça vous évite de venir
ouvrir de taper votre sms donc il ya un
vrai gain de temps et ça me semble
extrêmement pertinent et lorsque vous
avez cliqué up av vous l'avez ici petite
icône c'est validé c'est parti et ça
c'est bien on voit également l'arrivée
d'autres notifications sont des
applications vous verriez ici donc ça
pourrait être vraiment intéressant dans
cet écran de verrouillage qui aille plus
loin qui vous permettent de faire des
choses très rapidement pour optimiser
votre productivité et éviter de vous
déconcentrer à prendre votre iphone à
l'ouvrir puis vous savez qu'une fois
qu'on l'a ouvert on est souvent attirés
par d'autres applications de cage va
regarder si j'ai d'autres messages je
regardais mais y met en jeu les suisses
à nola vous le prenez vous répondez vous
le posez et hop on peut retourner à ce
qu'on fait ah c'était mon onzième point
notification j'ai un peu mélangé le
dixième est le onzième point on a
effectivement le dixième point l'écran
de verrouillage qui nous envoie sur le
onzième point en 11e point les
notifications et puis le 12ème point ça
serait un multitâche améliorée on
pourrait venir faire du multitâche de
tous les côtés pour améliorer la
productivité alors bien évidemment ça
reste un peu flou parce qu'aujourd'hui
ce sont des rumeurs sont des choses qui
circulent sur le web je vous ai fait un
tri de ce qui me paraissait tout cas le
plus intéressant et le plus pertinent et
les choses auxquelles je crois davantage
on verra maintenant tout ça au mois de
juin 2022 al adha badiou des bonnes
conditions on en parlera bien évidemment
l'adn ou isabelle houde ici donc je vous
invite dès aujourd'hui une fois de plus
à venir vous abonner s'est pas déjà fait
pour tout savoir sur les nouveautés
d'apple et notamment la table ou
d'abeille ou dc dc la portez vous bien
je vous embrasse de gros bisous de gros
becs et à très vite ciao
non
[Musique]